donne non riesco a sentirsi con delle
mistery box lui ne abbiamo tante non
sono solo queste ma chi si riferisse il
box questa volta diario da non vitale
giocare tutto le sceglierà si è pensato
per avete chiesto di fare altri video
consigli mi piacciono sempre tanti tutti
questi controlla le cose si litiga
qualcosa che video consigli si
risveglierà la mistery box dentro ogni
disse di momix ci sono degli interni si
parlò slime come sempre alcuni sono
fantastici e alcuni stato schifo sarò
abbastanza fortunato consiglieri questa
volta vediamo io voterò la mia sfinita
resterà la sua siri quindi vediamo un po
allestire e più buone ma quale più
cattiva lasciate un bel live
se volete vedere altre challenged line e
tutti gli altri sicuri nei commenti di
attrezzate di fare
prendete pop corn dallo schema inizia
questa vittoria l'inter
volevo ricordare che il mio bellissimo è
ancora scontato su amazon idee regalo
perfetto per natale ovviamente se non
avete ancora potete chiedere a babbo
natale oa chi volete
eccolo qua e lo avete già preso ce
l'avete già scrivetemi nei commenti se
vi è piaciuto quale ricetta vi è
piaciuta di più quale parte del libro di
è piaciuta di più e se volete potete
mandarmi su instagram di invest anzi ho
trovato la foto con il libro e la
repubblica nelle mie
dov'è finita a carta parole di sasso
carta file esitato allora abbiamo tre
scatolino iniziamo da queste piccoline 1
2 e 3
193 deve chiedere a siri di scegliere il
numero tra 1 e 3
va poi quella che rimane io dovrò
chiedere a sé di scegliere un nome tra 1
e 2 del mio numero tra 1 e 3 che brava
lepre ma dispone di medici tutti i
colori alla fine lo sai che le vecchie
comanda allora me rimangono la 1 e la
cui vediamo se mi risponde bene fini
temo si scegli un numero a caso tra 1 e
2 giuste risposte
brava brava stilista molto contento che
ti stai comportando bene o per me è la
numero uno ma ben rosso rosa di musica
allora cos'è rara che per gravità di
alte glitter verdi e dai non ci
scoraggiamo molto strani sono capitati a
te ne vediamo io no io ho dei pigmenti
viola strano bellissimi diventa adesso
allora prima di passare al prossimo
turno andiamo a mettere i nostri mentre
vediamo come dire ok vediamo come si
stanno di mister vero come ci saranno
verdi a bird su bianco la gente sa bene
per forza qualcosa di tele sempre con 20
colpi di coda di casa è contento perché
questo è il verde dello sliding bandai
dilatare basta che si scusa scusa questo
è il verde di natale che prenderà vita
il verde di natale erano albero di
natale e questo è il muschio di natale o
il rischio di deficit
questo è fatto si vedono poco i click
noi prendiamo cos'altro ti capiterà di
questi ti mette un po parlato un po
metallizzato v d avorio frattempo le
campane suonano come di volta che
facciamo i video
[Musica]
per ora sei stata più fortunata tu ha
detto per ora messo troppo poco non
l'ostacolo ora o giorno di mischiare
bene collaudo libro ebbene la sla in
rosa speriamo che non vi capiti nessun
altro colore
però non ha preso molto colore ok grande
numero due
abbiamo del 23 la prima è verde
vediamo chi inizia carta forbice sasso
carta forbice fatto che vediamo se si da
me cosa posso aiutarti cercarle da tra 1
e 3 4 ecco cosa ho trovato cercandosi li
dammi un numero orientalismi perché
posso perdere rosso che aveva lo
vendiamo
siri del mio numero tra 1 e 3 conoscevo
la voce molto l'italia perché colti
vitale non me posso certo peso
interessante ma lei mi chiamo ascolta
nella parte solo uso del più potente ed
evade
assente la carta dal numero 3
siamo per fittare sole se gliela 1 la 2
numero tra 1 e 2 1 ok quindi l'ora di
quanto non faccia allora primo il questa
cosa secondo te come cambierà il colore
del plus line in rosso il nero perché i
colori per si colorano la lune vero
quello che via via vitale ritriti e il
marrone diventerà probabilmente che tre
gambe ma non è finita qua perché abbiamo
decorazioni verdi spero gigante di berat
ersel data e rosse perché lo facciano
sopranzi qui però questo è bello dai ora
c'è un altro pigmento viola ma questo
permesso
lo stop era davvero bellissimo mi piace
fatto ancora peggio proprio tutto bene
il male vedere allora vabbè l'abbiamo il
colorante verso giusto carta ma poi
abbiamo i glitter e glitter argento sono
unite al carbone color carbone argentato
che è quello che brutto di tutti è
questo il mio odio questo è quella per
fare il zeligtube ma il profilo ponendo
sempre che fa tanti suoni non mi josef
allora facciamo scambio tummiolo ha
detto di prodotti questo da noi cambiamo
che io ti do allenare tumminello
marchionne o niente
allora ho messo innanzitutto il pigmento
viola vediamo se prende colore speriamo
così poi copre il nero di diamo questo
pigmento sì però non sono sta espandendo
molto non so se dovrei mettermi di più e
sembra uno yogurt ai mirtilli e come lo
fanno non si è diventato inviolate bene
il colore non è male
sarà un po di non più di pigmento
effettivamente
vediamo con il nero bpt speriamo che non
dimentica rizzo adesso diventa yogurt al
mirtillo tanto a scapito ci vediamo a
dai però una mano destra insomma la
scurito un po gli ho dato più di
mirtilli ma male visto che teneva molto
al mio
allora devo mettere in queste votazioni
purtroppo gente è certo che non bara
come te che fa testo
allora vediamo come si mischiano questo
il tiro a un pochino si vedono pensavo
che i colori non si vedessero poi però
un pochino si vedono qui per servire
slime fin ora vediamo quello di vitale
comincia subito dal verde
credi che già un po di colore appreso
nella maledizione del dente che facciamo
bello giornata verde sberluccicante
addio quanto nei vecchi sacco di verbo
mercato grazie per aver del verde che
abbiamo mai visto non sia colorato
tantissimo matti non so perché forse
perché sia un bel pò di colico alla
bianca robello sembra una bella monaca
di natale e ancora poi ci mettiamo le
crea tanto e carbone e ne abbiamo ancora
un bellissimo slalom verde con puntini
neri per aperto
sarebbe ora manca la spugna
20 chiesto non mi piace lo sponheim
anatemi giusta tra ora mi piace queste
distrazioni non mi piace due corazzieri
allarme questi sono i regali sotto
l'albero tutti bianchi incartati con la
casa bianca
beh non è male particolare lo so il mio
caso carta fare stato qui vediamo un po
che mi dicesti si danno un numero a caso
tra 1 e 3
ok quindi prendo la scatolina piccolina
rosa scusa di mio numero trasmettere il
mio numero tra 1 e 2
spetta a proprio non c'è niente che le
fortuna ho preso i pigmenti rossi ma
tutti i tour ei presidi di mente
e che siamo messi radio magari già da un
po più di colore vuoto sarà scatola
sporca posso aiutarti a trovare il posto
che cerchi solamente se attivi i servizi
di localizzazione doppiato mi commenti
di dire assiri o di fare il dub step che
li cantare una canzone dei suoi cantava
una canzone
[Musica]
come dire come fa la volta si ri
raccontare una barzelletta 2 alfano
entra meno belle
mi dispiace ho dimenticato al resto
tutto ok
presto il rischio è che mi aiuterà il
fatto che in questo periodo il tempo non
solo scatola vuota come è successo
questo bug del sistema ma mi dispiace
quindi il pigmento rosso lo metto dopo
prima facciamo pescare qualcosa che è
vitale poverino allora ne abbiamo due
questa volta che aveva paralizzato carta
farmi dato quindi io chiedo assini quale
scatola stile tra 1 e 2 e vitale prende
l'alta bene se vi sono il bravo noi due
che cosa ne 2
[Musica]
allora vedi che siri più testarda la mia
segretaria della tua stima mia
obbediente ti sei un numero tra 1 e 2
la risposta a meno male ma quello di
questo grande resta allora glitter
bruschi che va ancora bene apple mentre
il peggioramento del nascituro
adesso che prendi pure perdere capitata
vediamo cosa c'e nei capelli
[Applauso]
sì perché sono color pastello che
fortuna andiamo a metterli grosso che il
primo che mi è capitato col bellissimo
teatro bruciato e tipo metallizzato
fumetto di pisa massa catalli co vediamo
come diventa se ci saranno milioni di
colori in queste prime fiamme glitter
cloro serata dovrebbero starci bene
basta rete nei letti
che belli che si fanno un bell'effetto
poi il pigmento perdere vediamo se
magari non fa molto effetto cambiato un
sacco mannaggia
sicuramente non farà tanto effetto
diventerà tutto grigio gregorelli
vediamo almeno anche questo è un pò
metallizzato quindi farà un bel riflesso
che bello si sta colorando di verde non
è vera battaglia
ero diventato grigio e poi veramente se
ne vedono nei più diversi ma ci sono
troppi colori qua dentro però si vede
comunque il riflesso perdono 6 rifletti
poi per fortuna quasi 200
[Musica]
ma vediamo che bello del pallido dato
migliora tutta con il portiere pronto
quei dolori
no non ebbe veniale tua voglio vedere le
spugnette fallire e bellissimo solo che
le spugnette allora io devo solo
aggiungere le palline colorate e non so
altro pescatore rapporto
mettiamo le palline
[Applauso]
queste c'è da vedere galati ruolo firma
copie crescita al bahrain ma si è molto
delicato color menta e mese l'ultimo
turno i demo ride
magari un'altra scavano a volo d fino
alla quale mi piace quello digitale che
una certa di tenere trasmessa poi il mio
dai non c'è paragone guardare più bello
del mio allora ultimo round nel
frattempo intestato recupero delle
scatole più grande catena
attenzione questo è il turno decisivo in
cui vedremo se rovinerà per sempre lo
slime o se rimarrà bello chiamati sasso
hanno scritto k complice basso torniamo
alle nostre divergenze e l'antica con
una sfida di generazione di numeri
casuali
quindi dice noi non facciamo carta
complice tasto sulla i numeri casuali
che dovrebbero
l'ateneo incarico mercato ma nei boschi
la carta forbice sasso ascoltami bene
questa volta devi scegliere bene non
scegliere il verde dimmi un numero a
carta 1 e 3 non l'ho trovato bene non
sia nel verde dicendo che non c'è il
verde dei premi si in quale scatola tra
la 1 e la 36 il verde ecco quello che ha
trovato il grigio verde dove ristorante
sei un numero al caso tra 1 e 3
voglio applicazioni puoi usare
dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 3
la risposta è no grazie quindi prendo
questa scatola enorme
oddio testa ho paura pagamento dai tagli
si deve un numero tra 1 e 2
secondo i miei calcoli un primo lo
stesso vediamo cosa ci siamo persi
allora aspetta
devo aprire prima io vediamo ancora
presto per fare le capacità per il
pressing flime quindi dopo tanta ottima
alto dovrò fare un pressing clan in modo
che non hanno mai fatto quindi siamo qui
riuscirà che fortuna guarda ma non
quello proposto e poi dall'opera non ci
credo le corse che trento
adesso voglio anch'io un pigmento anche
se fosse verde ha fatto non c'era questo
è preso tutto vediamo la cosa che devi
più insieme alla stalla spugnetta da
vitale la odia l'italia
come recita la maglietta ecco allora la
prima chiudiamo posizione alla scatola
al bar a quella che non abbiamo scelto
noi siamo veramente ti capitava questa
parificare allora mettete innanzitutto
il pigmento giallo
vediamo se migliora la mail sia
bellissimo veramente esistono il
prodotto è brutto vizioso perché tutti i
colori sono capitati a meno latte che
bello
no è scomparso vabbè poi diventato di
maggio si vedrà dopo nei riflessi magari
così diventa bello sullo sfondo
completare il popolo ha messo troppa ma
vediamo vediamo se diventa bello corposo
anzi tra l'altro ore il colore si
schiarirà 15 spero davvero che non
diventeremo ceramica del comparto hi
certo lo swipe schivo la barba non
offrire sul colore
vabbè dai almeno numero degli stimoli
poi vedremo anche il pressing come s
allora cominciamo prima con i nostri
glitter e comunque non è male sembrano
macedonia verde ma ci pone a vedere
perché dei sims vedendo fa male ma che
diventano da neve in mezzo che fa sempre
vale su tutto non mi piace dare che
vuole permettere poi o catene
mettiamola promuova che ormai è stupendo
che il mio slime attivare il nostro
slime è potuto vedere potrete votare se
ho vinto io ho te ha vinto l'italia sia
un aspetto che per sony sta mr siete
pronti
true crime alla fine è uscito un colore
tipo violetto lille chiaro allora è a
scusate ancora poche cose non voleva
attirare purtroppo comunque è bene un
rapporto un po grassi non troppo come di
bambine
per oggi sono in libia sono tanto che
qui e ora
anche tra un po è rimasto incollato poi
ora vado a piazzarla cioè non male per è
rimasto un po sporca qua ne fa niente
ed ecco il mio bellissimo slime verde
verde chiaro chi bello allora guardiamo
primi i colori parte la tua assistenza
che bellissimo questo verde questo
venerdì quasi estate si sa sa di limone
e lime coi big blu grigi
verdi tra l'altro e queste palline tutte
intorno che sembrano tanti piccoli si
decise dal tis tiscali è uno slide
bellissimo sentire che può king ne ho
fatto di meglio in realtà perché la
spugnetta melo rovina dai cari non sono
soddisfatto non mi dispiace
rimane abbastanza più o meno flessibile
non si rompe il fuoco perché ho messo
tanto bicarbonato disabili è più soffice
valenti bello e mimmo pizzo vero allora
vantaggio totale se ho vinto io oggi ho
vinto io l'ho capito tutto ma per allora
mila sono affatto cartelline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
i nostri video challenge video
divertenti cliccate su quello che
preferite e coraggio